Thongo lam vuma
Lam vuma,
Thongo lam vuma,
Lam vuma, lam vuma,
(Improvisación)
(Fin de la música)
(Aplausos)
Thandiswa Mazwai: Hola a todos.
Gracias por la invitación.
Me llamo Thandiswa Mazwai.
Soy una mujer salvaje, cantante rebelde, una intermediaria.
Mi música es sobre la memoria
y la lucha entre la opresión y la libertad.
En Sudáfrica, después de 20 años,
nosotros, la inmensa la población negra,
aún seguimos sufriendo y luchando por nuestra libertad y humanidad.
La primera canción fue "Iyeza", que significa "medicina".
Medicina para nuestra locura, medicina para nuestra ira.
La canción que interpretaremos ahora se llama "Zabalaza",
que significa "rebeldía".
Quisiera dedicarla al valiente movimiento estudiantil de Sudáfrica
que protestó contra el alza de colegiaturas
(Aplausos)
y la remoción de la estatua de Rhodes.
Pero lo más importante
es la nueva fuerza que cobró el movimiento feminista.
Por eso, abajo el patriarcado.
(Aplausos)
(Música)
Gogo bek' umthwalo
Kunin' uhlupheka?
Niñito del gueto
Ungazibulali sana
Oh...
Si tomas mi mano,
te mostraré
cómo ser libre.
Ayifanelang' ub' iyenzeka lento
Emzini kabawo
kunge kudala
Sizozabalaza.
Zabalaza, zabalaza.
Zabalaza.
Sizozabalaza.
Zabalaza, zabalaza.
Zabalaza.
(Vocalización)
(Improvisación)
Es mi gente de Soweto,
mi gente de Mozambique,
mi gente de Senegal.
Esta es mi gente de los guetos.
Zabalaza, zabalaza.
Zabalaza.
(Fin de la música)
(Aplausos)
(Ovación)
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)